[Musique]
15 janvier 1919 boston dans le
massachusetts est le théâtre d'une
étrange tragédie dans le nord de la
ville alors réservoirs pleins à craquer
de mélasse 7
10 millions de litres de mélasse se
répandent dans les rues
[Musique]
le liquide épais et visqueux forment
alors une vague de plus de 4 mètres de
hauteur qui s'avance à une vitesse de 15
mètres par seconde démolissant tout sur
son passage
vingt-et-une personnes perdent la vie
dans cette tragédie et plus de 150 sont
blessés du jamais vu à l'époque les
enquêteurs ont déterminé que la
construction du réservoir était
défaillante mais cela n'explique pas
tout les propriétés physiques
particulières de la menace au rendu
l'accident dévastateur il faudra des
décennies ou scientifiques pour vraiment
comprendre ce phénomène
en 2016 une équipe de chercheurs de
l'unil as traveled à étudier les
propriétés de cette substance au repos
elle est presque vide
mais plus on lui applique de la pression
plus elles s'écoulent facilement comme
un liquide
une fois libéré de son réservoir la
pression de son propre poids a permis à
la mélasse de s'écouler à une vitesse
fulgurante
tel un tsunami pour vérifier leur
hypothèse les chercheurs ont recréé
l'événement à une échelle miniature en
utilisant du sirop de maïs qui a des
caractéristiques semblables à la mélasse
un autre facteur était en jeu la
température du mois de janvier dans son
réservoir
la menace était plutôt tiède mais au fur
et à mesure qu'elle s'est coulé dans les
rues de bostens elle refroidissait et
devenait de plus en plus visqueuse pour
les victimes qui étaient engloutis
jusqu'à la taille
il était presque impossible de s'en
extirper
cette tragédie a marqué l'histoire de
bostens de nos jours
la légende veut que lors des chaudes
journées d'été ont pu encore sentir les
effluves de mélasse dans le nord de la
ville
[Musique]